Irène Chagot propose voyage sans
passeport cette émission est réalisée
avec le concours de Jean G1 et de
Solange pter montageon s son gu Solignac
illustration nord de Nice
Glazer ce sont les Pyrénées pas comme
vous les avez vu cet été non mais comme
vous les verrez peut-être demain si vous
partez pour la
Colombie
toujours si vous allez en Colombie vous
ferez escale à San Juan de Porto Rico
sachez que l'ahérodrome est près de la
mer d'une escale on repart
toujours
je vous en préviens c'est à baronia que
l'on s'apprête à
atterrir et Bogota surgit vous vous
trouvez au milieu de
Bogota comment reconnaîtrez-vous Bogota
oh c'est simple par ce moyen il est
pratiqué dans presque chaque rue des
pièces de bœuf que l'on fait cuire à
même le
trottoir
mais oui vous avez raison ce sont des
vauours plus çavamment appelé hurubus
ils sont les boueus officiels et non
syndiqués de
Bogota bien sûr il y a aussi des maisons
riches ou pauvres elle se côtoie il y a
même aussi des buildings bien que là
vous ne les ayez pas vu Pandy k de
Bogota Pandy et son marché on a tout dit
sur les marchés alors je vous laisse
regarder
en France dans certains bist on peut
apporter son
repas ici vous allez le voir c'est au
marché qu'il est recommandé de le
faire on s'installe on déballe son
sac et on déj c'est tout
simple
voici les champssé de Pandy mais si
c'est
vrai vous aimez les autoroutes vous avez
raison
mais avouez que ces chemins ne sont pas
dénués de
poésie
quand une jeune fille de Pandy s'habille
dans l'uropéenne on a l'impression
qu'elle va aller un cocktail et bien pas
du tout elle va tout simplement faire
une
course tout est calme apparemment car
c'est un pays en perpétuelle
révolution qui nouveau s vu c'est ce que
vous ne verrez pas un barrage devait se
dresser au milieu de ces montagnes le
projet irréalisable dû être abandonné
néanmoins les vues nous
restent rivières
indisciplinées dont on ne peut rien
faire
routes et boulet d'où il est parfois
très difficile de sortir les routes les
mieux entretenues s'effondrent un jour
victime du pays tropical victime des
EAU broyeer de la canne à sucre pendant
2 he tourner jusqu'à l'épuisement
l'éblouissement total ne doit pas être
très
amusant
c'est par ce tuyau que s'écoule le
jus et dans ces bacs qu'il est
cuit
puis moulé dans des formes spéciales on
en fait des pains de
sucre entre d'un alchimiste ou sirop de
sucre de canne on ne sait plus très
bien et après une courte halte nous
voilà reparti pour deux autres
heures et toujours au pas de
course et la température n'a pas
diminué
ici encore une fois la nature l'a
emporté sur la civilisation on voulait
creuser un tunnel à cet endroit mais
cette région à l'intérieur des terres
était beaucoup trop inaccessible il
fallut y
renoncer
elles aussi se défendent bien le font
avec ardeur chacune porte une petite
feuille et toutes ces feuilles réunies
feront aidé par l'humidité ambiante une
champignonnière garde manger pour
iménopter
vous voulez aller voir à 500 m devant
vous ce qui se passe c'est très simple
faites comme lui un coup à droite un
coup à gauche et vous avez une chance
d'y
arriver
un peu
taquin tout à fait
charmant mutin apprivoisé en tout
cas
ici c'est le pays de Jano lapin la terre
est au premier occupant mais c'est tout
de même un régime capitaliste car c'est
celui qui aura les moyens d'entourer
avec une clôture la plus grande surface
de terre qui sera le plus riche
propriétaire terrien c'est simple mais
il faut encore pouvoir se procurer une
une
clature pays très
pieux la Vierge dans sa
niche
ce n'est pas une superstition ce n'est
même pas la peur de la route mais bien
une habitude une sorte de
salut avant l'envool une rapide vision
du lac de
Bogota
et nous voilà en plein ciel avouez qu'on
y est
bien